[Applause]
this is the biggest confrontation yet in
europe's latest migration crisis
this is the rising desperation of
thousands of people stuck on a border
that won't open for them this is poland
poland
and this is the consequence of a
humanitarian situation eu leaders say
has been cynically manufactured
the crossing at broski migrants and
refugees here are on the belarussian
side polish border forces to stop them
crossing into the eu use water cannon
and tear gas
at the front are mainly young men but
many women and children are in the
crowds behind
for those on the receiving end it's an
inhumane and hypocritical rejection by
europe
al jazeera's reporter on the ground
spoke with them this
they're using pepper spray and water and
tear gas against the children is this
the human rights of europe ten days
we've been here without water
temperatures are minus five and what can
we do where are the human rights
organizations we were a good country
they invaded iraq in 2003 we've lost
everything we've sold our cars and sold
our houses they've destroyed our country
and now this is their human rights
we haven't slept since yesterday our
feet are freezing and the only word we
can hear is attention attention we have
kids we have wives if they don't want to
allow us through then return us back to
our countries we haven't eaten for five
days only a little food is available for
women and kids we need a safe place we
need a safe country
it certainly is an uneven fight
but poland's authorities also want the
world to see its dilemma here as they
view it they're the victim holding fast
the eu's borders against a bella russian
dictator using desperate people as a
weapon
on tuesday that man held a meeting on
the crisis that western leaders say is
his revenge revenge against them for
sanctioning alexander lukashenka's
government for domestic political
repressions for months belarus has been
granting migrants visas promising them
an easy route into the eu that's turned
out to be an illusion
as i have told merkel the problem is
that we don't save those people we would
both lose both belarus and to an even
bigger extent the european union which
didn't let through the refugees to the
eu territory
that's why i proposed on solving the
situation in general we agreed with
merkel that we won't talk about it
specifically she asked for some time for
a pause to discuss the proposal with the
members of the european union that's
fine
while alexander lukashenko tries to
extract from the eu the concessions he
wants the situation on the border
worsens the numbers are growing the
temperatures are plunging and the
desperation increases and with it the
likelihood of more big clashes rory
challenge al jazeera
well let's bring in our correspondent
step fassen she's in the polish town of
kuch nietzsche on the other side of the
border from belarus whether those
clashes have been taking place
step watching that violence on the
border today that's really been quite
the escalation
absolutely these are really dramatic
pictures right here at the gate into the
european union of course these pictures
are not going down well here with many
in europe and although the polish
authorities call this all a provocation
they say this is exactly what alexander
lukashenka was after he wanted this
provocation he wanted these images going
around the world of showing how the eu
is treating
harmless and unarmed
refugees and migrants polish authorities
also say they were throwing stones and
locks at the border and that's how why
they responded so strongly one polish
officer got seriously ill his seriously
injured his skull is broken but on the
other hand these images will definitely
put more pressure also on the european
union to solve this crisis it's been
going on for weeks and months already
and the situation has definitely rapidly
deteriorated people are really getting
desperate now here in the winter stuck
between the two countries belarus one
side and poland on the other
and step we were earlier talking about
this propaganda war that you've just
alluded to there this diplomatic row is
certainly heating up and the eu
is now stepping up sanctions is that
going to have any impact
yesterday they slap more sanctions on
alexander lukashenka and the people
involved
as they say in this fabricated migrant
crisis orchestrated by belarus
by having easy entry visas for people
migrants and asylum seekers to enter uh
mints but we have seen that sanctions in
the past haven't really gone anywhere
they haven't had any effect and what's
happening now is that actually the
diplomatic channels with the disputed
leader that's who's been called a
dictator by european leaders are open
again
angela merkel the german chancellor had
a long phone conversation with alexander
lukashenko for 15 minutes yesterday and
he said today that they will have
another conversation soon something is
being offered something's being
negotiated so that's a real
significant point to mention because
before these diplomatic channels were
totally closed
for a year so now he is in charge
basically luka shankar he's pulling the
strings and everyone is of course really
wondering what is coming out of this uh
negotiation
step vassen there with all the latest
for us from very near the polish belarus
border thank you steph
well let's now bring in whittled klaus
he's a human rights lawyer he joins us
now from the polish capital warsaw which
all there are obviously a number of
conventions and protocols in place that
are meant to protect the rights of
refugees the eu also has the dublin
regulation for countries to take up
responsibility for those within its
borders now as a lawyer what do you make
of what happened today
i mean it happened what it's meant to be
happened and what was probably it was
planned a long time ago and should be
expected from from people in uh in
desperate situation because as
being said they are
trapped at the border between two fences
between two armies uh without food
without anything uh and without any
solutions without any hope what will uh
happen next to them and then what what
what will you offer to them uh so i mean
there was no no possibility for them to
to stay there that's why they
they try to
solve this by their own uh uh of course
using violence but it's it's new for the
situation at the border because
previously for the
first
first situation during the last several
months the the violence has been
deployed by by immigrants at the border
well whittled as you alluded to there a
lot of the people that we're talking
about here the men the women and the
children that we've seen today who are
trying to cross over they're stuck in
this
border area between countries this kind
of gray zone in that case what sort of
rights do they actually have
i mean they always have a right to uh to
apply for
asylum uh and there is only way that
could enter and should enter uh the gate
to the eu in this case to the to to
poland
uh but no one listened to them uh so
uh we don't know if they applying for
asylum do they want to that to do that
or not uh but nevertheless i mean they
they you should solve the situation on
the not only on the diplomatic level but
on the humanitarian level so in my
opinion those people should be entered
poland and
different procedures should be applied
to them either asylum or a return
procedure to
secure them
safe back homes
you talk about potential return
procedures we've actually been getting
reports of the opposite how bella
russian authorities are encouraging
migrants and refugees to try to cross i
mean even giving them wire cutters
showing them the way through the forest
you're sitting in the polish capital now
how's all of that going over in warsaw
i mean
it depends when i mean the government is
very uh very open about about their
policy they start they sealing the
border they don't want people uh uh
uh they uh they uh present themselves at
the defenders of the of the eu but there
is also another side of uh um presented
by activists by by regular members of
the society uh that and most of the
people do not accept those policies
maybe not most but a lot of people don't
accept the this policy and
and it's really embarrassed what the
government police government is doing
and
at the moment
well as we've seen the diplomatic spat
appears to be escalating between the eu
and belarus and a lot of people are
talking about the migrants and refugees
that we've seen today being used as
pawns where do you actually see this
going
actually i don't know i mean the the old
diplomatic situation is deployed to or
too late because the situation uh
started uh
in in june already uh on the belarus
lithuanian border and only now um
we see that something is going on at
least uh so
it's very late and it's very cold also
uh so those people are uh in a in a more
and more
difficult situation and more important
in a in a desperate uh so and if any
uh each government and i mean polish and
the nervous and don't want to
ban and to do anything to help those
people
i mean
we could uh even uh expect some some
debts on on the border and
we've seen uh uh several of them uh
already we have indeed and we're seeing
more of that desperation we told klaus
their human rights lawyer speaking to us
from warsaw thanks so much for joining
us on al jazeera whistle thank you